so so you grew up in St Louis I know
that you said your mom was at home what
else was it like I got siblings and
stuff it was it was cool like I had a
cool little childhood it was fun but you
know like being in in a single parent
household you don't get all the stuff
you want and stuff uhuh yeah well I got
a lot of hand-me-downs when I was
growing up yeah that's what I'm saying
like uniforms shoes all that but I don't
know that's just what how it is dealing
with a single parent I guess dude my mom
dated this guy he was like a mechanic or
something for a while and then two years
later I'm wearing his [__] uhuh not the
mechanic clo it said Mr Mike on the
pocket is you for real I swear to God I
hit like a gross FD and he was gone and
I was still wearing this [__] yeah I F I
felt like I was employed I wasn't I was
just in ninth grade and he had a uh it
was a mechanic shirt yeah he worked at
like a and he was wearing it like it was
a
shirt did did your mom date when y'all
were growing up what was that like yeah
she used a day but not like that but we
I did have a step daddy like like for a
while but he had got killed like when we
was younger yeah they was going together
for seven years and it was like like you
know somebody we looked up to he he
changed our life for real really yeah he
turned us up he used to um take us like
out of town
shopping all he had all cars he just was
like fun like a fun parent yeah and he
was so nice that was my step that you
and how did he pass away he I
nuh-uh yeah just in a neighborhood or
something he had a house and they came
thank you he had a house and they came
and knocked on um his daughter and
killed him his his friend they backo him
yeah damn when I a had my step daddy she
was doing working and stuff and then
even after he died like I could tell it
was hard on her but like she was just
like the man of the house type stuff
yeah my mom still she drivs for Amazon
she does like deliveries you know she
used to deliver her newspapers when I
was young and she [__] throw them
[__] boy
I'm dead bro one of her arms was so big
bro I said don't H you lying I said
don't hit me with that you was lying I
said don't hit me with that new so she
got stronger with one of her arms yeah
that [__] was
big she was pretty it was pretty big
dang that's kind of tight though and
that's the one I knew if I was
misbehaving a little bit I would get
this one I didn't want to get over to so
that's the one she was throwing the me
that's crazy that's tight she would
throw him out the window that's tight
but it been it's like that from like the
girls is the ones that get money they're
Brave huh yeah they get the money they
hard workers mhm the [__] live off the
girls where I'm from oh dang are they
doing that yeah that's a big thing out
there my mom's from the Midwest and
she's hardworking I'm from the Midwest
where your mama from she's from uh
Illinois she's from like outside of peia
for real yeah but she's always been a
hard worker that's the hardest working
man I've ever known as my mother that's
what I always say man that's how it be
that's how it was with my mama like she
was a real Hustler for real like where
did your mom work at she was a nurse oh
really yes she used to be at work all
day all she wore was scrubs and Crocs
all every day all day I just like man I
can't wait to get some money I'm I'mma
buy my mama some new clothes I'mma do
this cuz I just hated seeing her wear
the same clothes every day oh yeah and I
know she didn't really have it like she
had spent her last on us but still be
wearing the same scrubs like that was
her really like an outfit I hated it I
used be feeling bad for her she loved
y'all huh mhm yeah and does she live she
still lives in St Louis yeah no she live
with me she does well we got a house in
Miami oh wow
congratulations she quit working yeah
yeah I heard her her H her yeah yeah
just hir her be your mother that's the
best thing exactly she can chill watch
her grandkid you know if yeah I guess
and if his dad isn't around that's
probably the toughest part because he
can't build that relationship it is
tough yeah being a single parent like
even if I know I got it like I got the
funds and stuff to take care of my son
but you can't do daddy stuff like and my
son always ask for his daddy so that's
just hard I hate it for him yeah and you
can't even rent a that you can't do
nothing like that hell no he know he's
Daddy yeah you know he's daddy you can't
bring in like a no you can't even play
like that yeah yeah oh that's a bummer
do they have like do they have like
visits where you can go visit or no yeah
we be visiting them oh that's cool but
behind glass oh man so they can't touch
each other my son be putting his hand on
the window he'll bring his toys and be
playing toys I just be crying like this
is so sad I hate that for kids like kids
deserve their parents yeah and it make a
difference when you got your daddy in
your life too it really do yeah cuz they
used to the Mama being nurturing but
when you got your daddy it's like Dam
you got a daddy that's different you
know yeah that's different yeah
especially I think in poor communities
like a lot of the other kids in our
neighborhood we didn't have some people
had dads and you could tell there was a
little bit of a difference in the home
you know yeah that's what I'm saying
like it's it's different like dang you
got a ddy like you look you blessed you
look you got both of your parents in
your life I know I always admired that I
like to be over there at those houses
sometimes too yeah cuz I had a friend
she was the only one us that had her
daddy stealing her wife and when I say
she was spoiled we used to go to her
house she had a big old house she had
all the snakes all the clothes like she
was just like living life like it was
fun going over there her parents was the
best for real yeah my friend William his
his dad was there and we would go he
sometimes his dad would spank him I'd be
like spank me like like you want them to
be your daddy too yeah I just want in
yeah yeah oh God I just want to feel a
little Yeah just something you know yeah
oh they yelling at you too it's like now
you part of them like yell at me yeah
yeah you want to be a part of their
family they household yeah it's nice
it's important yeah and for Christmas
she used had all the toys all the good
gifts like all the good gifts and we
just sitting over there like like love
Mom and Dad and when it say that on
there you say dang yeah it's really a
it's sad to say but it's a blessing if
you could have both of your parents it
shouldn't be like that like yeah I think
it's one of the things that's tough in
the world is like people can't even AF
you know it used to be able to be a mom
I think it used to be able to be that a
mom could be at home with her kids and
now both parents they even have to work
if you do have both of them yeah you
know it's like they both got to be there
yeah
um but I think that's beautiful that you
want that for your son it's important
yeah and I yeah I think I would probably
like to have that when I have a family
yeah for sure you got to be a stand up
guy cuz dades is important yeah yeah
that's the thing I got to be ready to be
a daddy it's important though you know I
got to want to get up in the morning and
say yeah yeah put my shirt on Mr Mike
I'm going to be that man you know yeah
you can't be no lazy parent it ain't no
such thing cuz KS they no they keep you
up working you got to play with them all
day get them bath you basically got to
treat them like another you know like
it's you like whatever you do for
yourself no actually no cuz you might
want to lay around all day and do
nothing but your kids they want to be
active they want to do this do that and
you got to actually be ready to do that
you got to be engaged with them yes I be
tired but I sit there and still play
with him like I'm his friend or
something put him in the tub he hungry
all the time he always want juice oh he
always want something he he want to go
to the store I'll just be doing damn
yeah that's what I'm saying God damn he
really running
job yeah were you scared when you first
had him or
no yeah cuz it's like a new experience
like damn I got to look out for somebody
oh my God I was crying thinking about it
like my life is changing and you got to
set your alarm the next day even cuz you
got to get up mhm it was a big change I
was depressed too I was depressed and
then what happened he started growing
more into a person and it got easier
yeah it just got like fun and
interesting but I definitely was
depressed when I first had them like I
was really sad I don't know why well
that's called postpartum cuz I wasn't
used to it so it's like dang it's a
human I got to take care of it's hard
it's not easy and knowing this like f to
be with me for the rest of my life like
I'm F to get I can get a house I got
another person I got to look out for I'm
going to get food now I got to buy this
person some food it's just like it's
hard it's hard it's crazy and is it
what's the I guess if yeah I guess and
if his dad isn't around that's probably
the tough part because he can't build
that relationship it is tough yeah being
a single parent like even if I know I
got it like I got the funds and stuff to
take care of my son but you can't do
daddy stuff like and my son always ask
for his daddy so that's just hard I hate
it for him yeah and you can't even rent
a that you can't do nothing like that
hell no he know he's Daddy yeah you know
he's D you can't bring in like a no you
can't even play like that yeah yeah oh
that's a bummer do they have like do
they have like visits where you can go
visit or no yeah we be visiting them oh
that's cool but behind glass oh man so
they can't touch each other my son be
putting his hand on the window he'll
bring his toys and be playing on the
toys I just be crying like this is so
sad I hate that for kids like kids
deserve their parents yeah and that make
a difference when you got your daddy in
your life too it really does yeah cuz
they used to the Mama being nurturing
but when you got your daddy it's like
Dam you got a daddy that's different you
know yeah that's different yeah
especially I think in poor communities
like a lot of the other kids in our
neighborhood we didn't have some people
had dads and you could tell there was a
little bit of a difference in the home
you know yeah that's why I'm saying like
it's it's different like dang you got a
Dy like you look you blessed you luy you
got both of your parents in your life I
know I always admired that I like to be
over there at those houses sometimes too
yeah cuz I had a friend she was the only
one us that had her daddy stealing her
wife and when I say she was spoiled we
used to go to her house she had a big
old house she had all the snacks all the
clothes like she was just like living
life like it was fun going over there
her parents was the best for real yeah
my friend William his his dad was there
and we would go he sometimes his dad
would spank him I'd be like spank me
like like you want them to be your daddy
too yeah I just want in yeah yeah God I
just want to feel a little Yeah just
something you know yeah oh they yelling
at you too it's like now you part of
them like like yell at me yeah yeah you
want to be a part of their family they
household yeah it's nice it's important
yeah and for Christmas she used to have
all the toys all the good gifts like all
the good gifts we just sitting over
there like d love Mom and Dad and when
it say that on there you say dang yeah
it's really a it's sad to say but it's a
blessing if you could have both of your
parents it shouldn't be like that like
yeah I think it's one of the things
that's tough in the world is like people
can't even AF you know it used to be
able to be a mom I think it used to be
able to be that a mom could be at home
with her kids and now both parents they
even have to work if you do have both of
them yeah you know it's like they both
got to be there
um but I think that's beautiful that you
want that for your son it's important
yeah and I yeah I think I would probably
like to have that when I have a family
yeah for sure you got to be a stand up
guy cuz daddies is important yeah yeah
that's the thing I got to be ready to be
a daddy it's important though you know I
got to want to get up in the morning and
say yeah yeah for put my shirt on Mr
Mike I'm going to be that man you know
yeah you can't be no lazy parent it
ain't no such
thing they no they keep you up working
you got to play with them all day get
them bath you basically I treat them
like another you know like it's you like
whatever you do for yourself no actually
no cuz you might want to lay around all
day and do nothing but your kids they
want to be active they want to do this
do that and you got to actually be ready
to do you got to be engaged with them
yes I be tired but I sit there and still
play with him like I'm his friend or
something put him in a tub he hungry all
the time he always want juice oh he
always want something he he want to go
to the store I just be doing damn yeah
that's what I'm saying D he really
running around job you hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one